[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous avec l'été
arrive le soleil elle a envie de lire le
temps de lire nous allons vous donner
envie de lire c'est tellement important
henry miller disait de temps en temps
j'allais passer une soirée à la
bibliothèque municipale pour lire c'est
pour moi prendre un billet pour le
paradis
alors on va essayer de vous donner des
billets pour le paradis nous sommes cinq
passionnés de livres
nous avons su si mal très inquiets
poétesse prix vendée globe
bree foulon de vaud à versailles
président du salon du livre de
rambouillet monica de miniac conteuse
animatrice de radio marmite membres de
la société qui a fondé l'association
pirouette qui fait un pont entre
l'afrique et la france
patricot tagliani auteurs et éditeurs il
veut le courage vous lancez une maison
d'édition hervé lozach scénariste
réalisateur et auteur d'un des romans
très intéressant mais moi même donc
j'étais journaliste maintenant je suis
auteur les organismes salon du livre à
elancourt qui aura lieu le 24 novembre
donc nous allons débuter avec suzy suzy
maltret qui va nous parler de poésie je
crois je vais vous parler bien sûr de
poésie puisque l'an dernier c'était le
centenaire de 14-18 et que sous
l'impulsion de gérard larcher
donc j'ai écrit ce livre qui s'appelle
là bas là-bas tout simplement parce que
oui la plupart n'ayant jamais voyagé
partait là-bas sans savoir
voilà et ce fut la surprise que
ces 55 poèmes soit reconnue par les
écrivains combattants
depuis lors je suis donc écrivains
combattants pour l'éternité
voilà les mots nico donc vous avez un
livre un roman que vous a passionné qui
la couleur des sentiments de karim diop
quel coach stockett
voilà j'ai aimé ce livre parce que
j'admirais le courage de 2,2 deux femmes
noires à l'époque en 1962 au mississippi
qui s'occupait des enfants des blancs et
qu'ils vivaient les choses difficilement
et une jeune femme blanche qui était
surprenant s'est mis à les prendre en
considération d'autant plus qu'elle
elle aimait énormément sa nourrice et
qui est un qui avait disparu il savait
elle savait plus ce qu'elle était et
elle a éprouvé le besoin de faire parler
de donner la parole à ces femmes et et
qui est
c'était courageux de sa part et de la
part des femmes noires de lui parler
donc voilà c'est ça a été mis en film je
vous conseille de le lire cet été le
film est très réussi et ça pose le
problème du racisme
si ce n'est toujours pas réglée aux
états unis et donc patrick octavian il a
donc qui a créé une maison d'édition et
qui est l'excellente idée de faire
ressortir la mémoire d'eugène dabit je
vais vous parler en premier de plutôt de
kiosques de kiosques c'est un livre qui
était publié par jean rault en début
d'année et qui est publié aux éditions
grasset et
avec ce livre on revient sur son métier
de kiosquier parce qu'ils étaient closes
qui à paris des années 1983 1990 il
était rude et flandre dans le 19ème
arrondissement et parallèlement à ceux à
ce métier de kiosquier et s'escrimer à
écrire son premier roman qui aboutit au
sésame c'est à dire au prix goncourt
1990 avec les champs d'honneur dans
lequel il relate pour ce livre là en
particulier toute la ville dans son pays
nantais
et puis qui a trait aussi à la guerre
14-18 etc
mais pour en revenir au mieux au kiosque
il revient il revient donc sur son passé
il parcourt les chemins de son passé et
c'est un véritable balcon sur rue dans
les années 80 90 rue des flandres ou à
son kiosque où il a 3000 revu il ya une
véritable vie populaire qui instaurait
et viennent des vietnamiens des
yougoslaves des pieds noirs des
argentins et c est à la fois les
nouvelles du monde que vient de recevoir
les gens piochant dans les journaux et
aussi pour pour jean rault une manière
de se réconcilier avec avec le monde
il fait il a le monde des éclopés de la
rue il avait que ce milieu populaire des
19e arrondissement et puis petit à petit
petit à petit il écrit les cris les cris
et puis un beau jour en 1990 il cesse
son métier de kiosquier puisqu'il et les
prix goncourt et donc s'ouvre une
carrière et puis une oeuvre maintenant
qui est considérable et ce livre là ça
fait piot ce que fait partie de fait
partie de ce qu'il appelle la vie une
classification dans ses écrits qu'elle
appelle la vie poétique et là on est
dans la tradition des écrivains de la
rue quoi comme henry miller blaise
cendras très humanistes il est oui oui
les îles et il est un écrivain delà de
la rue oui décrit les mêmes les milieux
populaires comme avec le champ d'honneur
et décrivait aussi les milieux
populaires mais là du pays nantais
d'outils l'énergie en fait sa vocation
d'écrivain elle est venue parce que le
26 décembre un lendemain de noël à l'âge
de 11 ans il a perdu son père et son
père c'était une grande figure de la
résistance c'était un homme très
important dans la loire atlantique et
l'a jamais fait le tout à fait le deuil
de son père et
et puis comme il avait fait ses études à
nantes qu'il avait eu un bac
scientifique be après la fait une
maîtrise de lettres et puis sans trop
savoir vers quoi il allait se lancer
tout ça et puis petit à petit la
littérature est venu en lui lui en lui
puis maintenant il ya une oeuvre
considérable il a dû publier une
trentaine de livres mais le point de
départ c'étaient les champs d'honneur
qu'avait été beaucoup beaucoup encensé
par patrick kéchichian dans le monde des
livres belles années 90 quoi puis a fait
un avec une écriture extraordinaire et
et kiosques s'il revient sur les chemins
de ceux du passé une trentaine d'années
après c'est dommage qu'ils aient moins
losc à paris il ya beaucoup de choses
qui au fanal pièce qu'il avait rue des
flandres a disparu parce que ils
modifient paris dans paris il faut le
savoir il ya peu près 1000 chantiers
mille chantiers de travaux publics de
tous genres tous les jours donc il
modifie modifié il arrange depuis le
kiosque a disparu mais il revient sur ce
sur cet endroit où il retrouve le
kiosquier avec lequel il prenait
travailler parce que lui travaillait de
l'après-midi et puis le premier dossier
travailler le matin à l'ouverture dès
l'ouverture des journaux des magazines
et tout ça donc hervé lozach de vous
aide à vous venez de sortir un roman qui
est vraiment très intéressant maubuisson
c'est l'histoire de terbi sont un
comptable qui ne veut plus comptés il y
aura eu plein d'aventurés volonté
beaucoup plus la wii alors d'un pierre
buisson car bichon donc et comptable il
se trouve qu'elle a à la veille des
vacances
son patron lui et afflige 2h02 de
travail supplémentaire et c'est un peu
la goutte qui fait déborder aborde en
déborder le vase merci beaucoup débordé
le vase
mais une goutte une goûte assez attendu
parce qu'en fait il est issu fob dans sa
vie dans son métier et
et certainement il attendait ce prétexte
pour pour une bascule qui va être
l'objet de tout le roman puisque il
cogite il a cogité depuis des mois une
façon de pouvoir sortir de sa condition
aliénante à ses yeux et 7 ce projet
puisqu'il appelle ça le projet va être
deux durant ces vacances d'été avec sa
femme au camping de devenir écrivain
dans la son projet alors ça va pas se
passer tout seul en fait il va avoir
pour le mois beaucoup de difficultés à
pouvoir écrire le moindre mot mais là
comment dire le choix de vouloir écrire
va l'amener à vivre toute une série de
péripéties hautement digne du roman
qu'il n'aurait jamais imaginé voilà donc
des personnages étonnants
alors oui c'est des péripéties alors
cfcm s'est plaint de rencontre alors il
ya une histoire d'amour avec une un
personnage avec une femme très
singulière et déterminante dans son
histoire tous singuliers aussi
déterminant la rencontre avec un chaman
qui est un un petit indien qu'il va
croiser par hasard mais il n'y a aucun
hasard en fait dans toute cette histoire
tout et tout est tricoté à mesure dans
son inconscient et son inconscient étant
de désirer
de tout coeur nous paraît qu'un roman
mais réécrire sa vie voilà la couverture
à l'intéressante elle était faite avec
deux feintes avec du café
alors il ya 2 il ya deux éléments il ya
le bateau et le café parce
qu'effectivement il va y avoir une
histoire de café ils cherchent
absolument à retrouver cette femme qui
l'a qu'il a croisés et avec le seul
souhait de prendre un petit café avec
elle et puis le bateau alors là c'est
tout un symbole
c'est une réalité aussi dans le livre et
puis aussi c'est le fait que en fait lui
qui fait un petit peu des ronds
circulaire sur son petit canot et va
devoir mettre un pied puis un genou à
terre pour embarquer beaucoup plus large
la sédition métaphore aussi ne devait
pas nommé mais mais ça ça y ressemble
aussi clairement pour les noms et c'est
fait alors ses écrits avec eux des
scènes qui sont poignantes mais aussi
avec beaucoup d'humour quoi cessons de
nous derrière et le soja l'oeuvre de
dents au cas tout le monde tout le monde
vit bien et régicides déjà aboli alors
un autre livre à lire pour l'été si je
peux vous conseiller c'est la
correspondance entre blaise cendras
henry miller entre les années 1930 4 mai
ce sont deux grands écrivains du xxème
siècle qui ont fait bouger les lignes
des écrivains de la rue des gens qui se
nourrissait de la rue et que de grands
humanistes aussi et donc en 1900 dans
son livre henry miller les livres de ma
vie il fait tout un chapitre sur blaise
cendras pour lui blaise cendras c'est
vraiment un très grand écrivain et quand
il était à paris à la villa sera là où
il est en résidence il dit le premier
écrivain français que j'ai rencontrés
c'était blaise cendrars et quand il est
reparti aux états unis le dernier
derniers écrivains français que j'ai vu
c'était blaise cendras et inhabitée
formidable ils ont correspondu
s'échanger leurs livres tout ça et quand
bhl henry miller et a créé arrivée à
paris dans les années 30 il avait rien
publié
c'était vraiment il était un peu il
avait quitté son emploi de des postes à
new york
il était un peu à la rue et donc ils
n'arrivaient pas à se faire publier
et alors que blaise cendrars était un
personnage important en 1930 à paris à
un héros de guerre qui avait perdu le
bras droit alors qu'il n'était pas
obligé d'aller à la guerre en tant que
suisse donc il a laissé son bras droit
il écrivait de la main gauche qu'elle
quel exemple de volonté tout ça et ils
ont sympathisé tout de suite il se passe
quelque chose
ils sont toujours aidé et henry miller
est toujours été admiratif de blaise
cendras et blaise cendras faisait
connaître l'oeuvre d'henry miller à
paris et inversement henry miller
faisait la promotion de blaise cendrars
à paris avec est là avec leurs lettres
on a toute la vie quotidienne de ces
époques de l'entre-deux-guerres et tout
est dans les correspondances de blaise
cendrars aussi chez zoé
vous avez la correspondance avec ram
raimon du château avec blaise cendrars
pause autres au cimetière du tremblay
sur le monde
à 15 kilomètres d'ici le tremblay sur
mauldre où elle habitait à la salle à ce
métier là le grand poète libanais qui
avait été le président d'honneur du
premier salon du livre des locaux il ya
deux ans et donc vraiment du château
avaient une maison où trembler sur maul
et c'est là que que blaise cendrars
venait régulièrement son alfa romeo
rouge mais c'est très intéressant aussi
cette correspondance ce qu'on voit ce
qui s'est passé pendant la guerre de
39-45 blaise cendrars a été complètement
effondré par la défaite de 48 qui avait
laissé son bras droit en 1915 il a été
effondré il a eu trois ans de dépression
il a mis longtemps à ressurgir et tout
mais vraiment c'est un très bon livre
alice cet été dans les correspondances
vous avez aussi la correspondance entre
henry miller anaïs milieu anaïs nine le
grand amour de sa vie anaïs qui aussi
une très grand écrivain
il faut lire son journal une bonne idée
de les visiter aussi merci à tous et à
toutes de votre écoute
bon été et bonnes lectures
[Musique]
m